good morning Hank it's Friday and for
those of you who don't know me my name
is Maureen Johnson and I am going to be
filling in for John Green while he's off
being a father so you're going to be
stared at my face for the next few days
few weeks or months if you don't know
who I am I am a friend of John's a
fellow Y author best known to any of you
nerdfighters probably as the person who
originated the joke in your pants and
you may also know me by my most common
title which is second prettiest green
brother but really what I am is the cone
into John's Leno because he's just
giving me the show and he's just gonna
take it right back for me really he
picked me because I'm not very good at
videos and he just wants you to want to
come back I mean I don't know anything
about videos the only thing I've learned
watching John and Hank is that you're
supposed to move your chair every once
in a while so I'm just going to do that
for like I don't know two hours how how
long have these videos to I don't
they're I assume they're two hours right
good so because that's how long this
one's going to be and honestly this this
wouldn't really even be an issue if John
just could you know keep it in his pants
I had to say it at some point anyway if
you have any comments about my
performance because I I really want to
do a good job and you know it's sort of
you know kind of how's my driving thing
don't even bother sending them to here
because I'm not going to go through
their mail send them to me on Twitter
I'm just Maureen Johnson all one word
and I'll read them so if you want to say
I like your style or you know you're
doing a great job or you stock I hate
your face or something like that that'd
be great and you send them to me there
and I'll Reno so anyway did John that
you know I love it
you know he's sort of like the John that
I know and love but there's another side
to John that I feel like I can I can
really help you explore and there's you
know in our time together and as it
happens luckily enough I have a little
footage that I shot of him while he was
here before he moved and I put it
together and in a little video I think
you you
little little Oh Maj Maj to John that I
think you're going to enjoy
it
you